[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt hähnchenflügel aus dem
ofen und zwar werde ich sie jetzt gleich
marinieren und später zu salat servieren
und ihr könnt diese marinade die ich
gleich mache auch zum beispiel zum
grillen verwenden ich hätte jetzt im
ofen machen weil wir uns heute auch
nicht so schönes wetter zum grillen aber
wie gesagt könnte es auch auf dem grill
machen da werden sie nämlich auch
richtig schön knusprig ich zeige euch
jetzt mal die zutaten ich brauche dafür
drei esslöffel honig eine zitrone drei
esslöffel süßes paprikapulver einen
halben teelöffel chili einen teelöffel
salz einen halben teelöffel curry und
eine knoblauchzehe etwas pfeffer sechs
esslöffel sonnenblumenöl ein teelöffel
senf drei esslöffel tomatenmark 1 2
esslöffel tabasco und 1 5 bis zwei kilo
hähnchenflügel jetzt werde ich zuerst
einmal die marinade herstellen dafür
gebe ich jetzt drei esslöffel honig in
eine schüssel und die marinade ist so
bis ins süßlich und säuerlich leicht
scharf und sehr würzig ich finde sie
wirklich super da kommen jetzt die
gewürze mit rein
und ihr könnt jetzt zum beispiel auch
chili weglassen oder noch mehr mit dazu
geben ja es heute ist ein bisschen
mitgehalten mit einem haaren teelöffel
aber für mich persönlich wäre ein
bisschen zu mir ich würde sogar noch ein
bisschen was rein geht jetzt noch
ordentlich pfeffer rein
[Musik]
jetzt auch öl rein
und tomatenmark und senf tomatenmark
gibt den hähnchen dann später auch die
tolle farbe
und das macht auch so bis fruchtig im
geschmack
[Applaus]
die knoblauchzehe reibe ich jetzt fallen
[Musik]
und die zitrone zerdrückte ich ein
bisschen r lässt sich das rad besser
auspressen und da gebe ich jetzt den
ganzen saft mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt nur noch tabasco
jetzt werden alle zutaten mit einem
schneebesen sehr gut verrührt
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die hähnchenflügel mit rein
und dann müsst ihr die marinade richtig
gut einmassieren am besten macht ihr das
direkt mit den händen
[Applaus]
dass die hinten flügel komplett mit der
marinade bedeckt sind
[Musik]
lass dir die hähnchenflügel am besten
noch ein bisschen durchziehen da für
dich jetzt mit einem deckel ab und
stellt sie für etwa vier stunden den
kühlschrank ihr könnt sie aber zum
beispiel auch schon am abend vorher zu
bereiten oder morgens zu bereiten und
abends beim grillen
für die hinteren flügel habe ich jetzt
hier was vorbereitet und zwar habe ich
einen parkplatz da werde ich sie gleich
drauf packen damit der die flüssigkeit
und das öl dann immer schön abtropfen
kann und unten dran werde ich ein
backblech reinschieben mit backpapier
damit einfach jetzt nix in den backofen
eindruck man nicht so viel arbeit hat
jetzt sehen wir die flügel und legt sie
zuerst einmal auf die hautseite also
jetzt nicht so sondern falsch rum da
können sie so nämlich zuerst einmal 20
minuten im ofen garen und nach 20
minuten wende ich sie und setzte dann 20
minuten fertig garen und in der zeit
bestreite ich sie dann auch mit dem öl
also nach dem umdrehen und so habt ihr
einfach nicht die gefahr dass die
hähnchenflügel auf der oberfläche
verbrennen
[Musik]
die zimmer sind jetzt fertig und ich
noch richtig schön gebräunt
ich werde dazu etwas salat servieren und
zwar jetzt einen gemischten salat
gemacht mit eisbergsalat und bisschen
tomaten zwiebeln und so weiter und haben
honig senf dressing dazu gemacht da kann
ich euch das rezept auch gerne unten
verlinkten jetzt wird es eigentlich
direkt schon serviert
und die chicken wings ist ein wirklich
sehr aromatisch schmecken so leicht
süßlich etwas scharf und sind wirklich
total hört sich also der murat markt
dies sehr gerne nicht richte die dann
hier auf dem teller an
[Musik]
da kommt dann etwas salat
und dann noch etwas dressing drüber
da hat man richtig leckeres essen noch
besser schmecken sie mir sogar also sind
sie schon richtig gut aber noch besser
schmecken sie mir wenn sie vom grill
kommen das werden wir dann demnächst mal
machen sobald das wetter bei uns wieder
besser ist wenn ihr jetzt das rezept
nach machen wollt dann geht auf meinem
blog sallys - block täter stets noch mal
für euch und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]